[Music]
you probably already love Disney
Princesses and this is why you will be
happy to hear that they're even more of
them make sure you watch this video
until the end to know who is the young
girl that fans used to call The
Forgotten Disney Princess if you love
Disney Princesses as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you ten Disney Princesses
you never heard of Anastasia some of you
probably thought that Anastasia was a
Disney movie and you would have been
wrong until recently
that's because Disney acquired Fox in
December 2017 for more than 52 billion
dollars this is what makes Anastasia a
Disney princess
she already looked like one and we are
happy to say that she can now join the
group the story was inspired by the
grand duchess anastasia nicolaevna of
russia in a movie that was more
appropriate for kids than the original
story anya used to live in an orphanage
but did remember the life that she used
to live before she arrived this is why
she went on a journey to understand what
really happened to her she met two men
who wanted to dress her to turn her into
princess Anastasia that's because her
grandmother offered a reward to anyone
who would find the young princess but
what they didn't know was that Anya was
actually the real Anastasia when he
found out about it Rasputin tried to get
rid of her but you'll have to watch the
movie to know what happened many people
said that Anya was easily the strongest
most independent animated female to
grace the screen at that time surpassing
even Belle this is why we are really
happy to see that she is now part of the
Disney family we need kids to watch good
role models like this melody every
Disney Princess sequel was a failure but
that doesn't mean that we didn't like
the characters one of those we liked the
most was probably melody from The Little
Mermaid to return to the sea she was the
daughter of Ariel and Prince Erik which
makes her a princess both on a land and
under the sea unfortunately the young
girl couldn't go anywhere near water
because it was too dangerous when
Ursula's sister was there
Morgana was planning revenge and Ariel
didn't want her daughter to be involved
in the conflict this was why melody
never had the chance to know anything
about the sea including her mermaid
heritage you probably guessed what would
happen when she grows up melody never
knew why she was banned from entering
the sea so she regularly sneaked out to
swim when her mother found out about
this she tried to stop her but we know
that girls don't listen to the rules in
this family she decided to run away her
actually row away in a boat
that was when she was lured to Morgana's
Lair who used a potion to turn melody
into a merman what will happen next
you'll have to watch the movie to find
out by the way we also got the chance to
see Ariel sisters attina Alana Adela a
quater Arista and Audrina as they are
the daughters of King Triton we
shouldn't forget that they are
princesses - Chanel Oberlin
now that Disney owns Fox a ton of her
favorite female characters are going to
become Disney Princesses but they also
need the status we think that Chanel
Oberlin from scream queens deserves to
be treated like a princess she used to
be the president of Kappa Kappa Tau and
had an army of minions called the
Chanel's unfortunately everything went
wrong when the Red Devils started taking
the lives of all of her friends stop
ruining the party no matter what chanel
kept her head up and managed to look
fabulous in front of a murderer not a
lot of people can say that not because
they are not fabulous but because they
try to avoid murderers anyway even
though most people would think that
Chanel was just a beautiful little
princess she showed everyone that she
could also be a scream queen and no
matter what we're always surprised by
all the things she managed to achieve
unfortunately in the second season
Chanel was disowned by her family this
is why she had to work as a medical
student in a weird Hospital along with
the other Chanel's if you watched the
second season until the end you know
that she will have a chance to become a
queen once again but we'll let you watch
the TV series so you'll find out about
that all by yourself we have to tell you
this show is absolutely worth it
vanellope von schweetz here's another
princess who is not like any other she
was one of the heroes and record routes
and we immediately knew that this Disney
movie would be different vanellope was
the main character of the video game
sugar rush and also used to be the
in-game world's princess unfortunately
King candy hijacks sugar rush and try to
delete vanellope turning her into a
glitch instead and making sure that
everyone would forget about her this is
how the candy King was able to rule the
kingdom the only way princess vanellope
could be back on the throne was by
crossing the finish line in an official
race this is why the evil character made
everyone believe that a glitch like her
would ruin the game and they started
bullying her however turning into a
glitch gave her the power to teleport
from place to place in the blink of an
eye that makes her one of the coolest
Disney Princesses even though she didn't
have much control over it unfortunately
years of bullying is all
so what made her annoying obnoxious and
rude but deep inside her princess
vanellope has always been loving and
loyal to those who liked her do you
think that someone will give her a
chance you'll have to watch
wreckit-ralph to find out about it the
white witch
here's another Fox movie that was bought
by Disney okay so technically Jada's
from Narnia is actually a queen but that
means that she has been a princess
before so she deserves a place on this
list Queen Jadis also known as the white
which used to be the sole living
resident and the self-declared queen of
the world of charm that was because she
spoke to the deplorable world which is
strong enough to destroy all living
things except the caster she was then
accidentally brought to the world of
gnarnia and she decided that she would
become the most infamous ruler of this
world too she had the power to force
Narnia into a hundred years state of
winter and this is why she earned the
title of white witch
it wouldn't be that bad but then she
also banned the celebration of Christmas
which made things worse than ever no one
wanted to confront her as they were
afraid of her powers that was until she
was overthrown by two sons of Adam and
two daughters of each just like the
prophecy predicted if you want to know
how four kids manage to do that you'll
have to watch the movie but we have to
admit that if we ever lived in a Disney
movie we think that Elsa from frozen
would be a better Queen she made winter
much more enjoyable
peeta peeta Kakashi doc also known as
Keita was one of the heroes of not only
one Disney movie but actually two
Atlantis the lost Empire and Atlantis
Milo's returned as the daughter of Kasia
kameena doc king of Atlantis she had
everything it takes to be a queen but
why wasn't she a Disney Princess like
all the others that we know Keita didn't
just wait around for a prince to come
she was the leader of a small group of
hunters one day she noticed a large
group of outsiders and wanted to help
them however the father wanted them to
leave with no explanation Keita later
found out that the group was there to
steal the heart of Atlantis which was
the power source keeping the city alive
what will key to do to protect her city
she will be the hero of her own destiny
the filmmakers always wanted Keita to
stand out from other Disney Princesses
both in appearance and in personality
she wasn't a damsel in distress but a
warrior woman who had everything she
needed to achieve her own goals
however the classic Disney Princesses
were already really popular and it was
risky to make such a change at that time
we think that Keita deserves
and chance and this is why you should
watch Atlantis the lost Empire but maybe
not the straight-to-dvd sequel
Neytiri we've seen Disney Princesses of
many different origins but we never
thought that one of them would be blue
that was Neytiri from Avatar the Navi
princess of the Amedda kya clan she
lived a beautiful life as she grew up
learning to love and to celebrate her
connection with all other life through
songs she was really similar to a Disney
princess after all but unfortunately her
worst enemies were the humans that was
until she met Jake Sully a genetically
engineered body of a human
Navi hybrid also called an avatar she
didn't trust him until something told
her that he was actually pure she even
saved him when he was attacked by a pack
of Viper wolves even though she wasn't
supposed to hurt any living creature
however not everyone agreed that Jake
was a friend and this is why the leaders
of the clan had to decide his fate they
finally said that he could stay with
them but Neytiri had to teach him the
ways of the people and as they work
together the two began falling in love
with each other the movie Avatar proved
that a princess can be the hero of her
own story and fall in love but also
learn how to fight for what is right she
was not waiting for a prince charming to
save her and this is what makes her a
great role model odda and goth
Pixar movies are Disney movies too and
that means that two of her favorite
characters from a bug's life are
actually Disney Princesses
adda was the eldest daughter of the
queen of the ant colony while dot was
the youngest and adda had to face one of
the biggest challenges of her life in
the movie she was close to inheriting
the crown from her elderly mother and
she had to be prepared for this this is
why she was very nervous regarding her
newfound responsibilities and she also
had another thing on her mind
adda had to deal with this little
troublemaker called Flik who happened to
be friends with her little sister died
she was actually a little too little
because she hated being small and wished
that she could be like Flik and he
turned out to be even better than we
imagined when the bugs he recruited
saved little but that was when adda
started being interested in him and we
could even say that she had a little
crush but just a little
because Flik was still causing a lot of
trouble you know that in movies things
are never as easy as it seems what will
happen next you'll have to watch a bug's
life to find out more about two Disney
Princesses that are not like any other
Tilda thanks to Fox Kingsman became a
Disney princess movie that grown-up men
will love to watch even though there is
nothing wrong with a grown-up man who
the classic Disney Princess movies
anyway crown princes Tilda of Sweden was
one of the heads of state and VIPs who
met Richmond Valentine to discuss about
global warming she thought that he was
completely insane and this is why she
was locked away in his base in the
mountains she was later discovered by
eggsy who asked for a kiss if he freed
her since he never kissed a princess
before till they didn't only agree she
said that she would give him much more
than that if he freed her but only
grownups who watch the movie will know
what that thing is they finally started
dating each other but tilde stayed home
while eggsy was on a mission involving
an intimate relationship with a woman
and once again Tilda got in trouble and
he had to save her we think that
Kingsman is great and really well-made
this is why we wish that Tilda could be
just as great princesses should be able
to do more than simply be a beautiful
woman in distress we'll still give her a
chance and hope that she will be better
now that she is a disney princess i
Loney she was one of the heroes of the
Black Cauldron a Disney movie she even
used to walk around Disney parks during
the release of the movie unfortunately
it didn't perform well compared to other
Disney movies so she didn't make it to
the official list this is why i Loney
was nicknamed the forgotten disney
princess but we still think that she
deserves our attention alone e was taken
hostage by the Horned King who hoped
that he could find the legendary Black
Cauldron while she was trying to escape
she met a farm boy named Taryn and he
decided to leave the castle together
they then went on a journey together to
find the Black Cauldron until they were
captured again by the Horned King what
is he going to do this time we'll let
you watch the Black Cauldron to know
what happens at the end even if there is
some love in this movie I'll only knows
how to be the hero of her own story she
didn't need a man at some point but he
needed her just as much and that's how
every Disney movie should be which is
your favorite Disney Princess among
those we can see on this list don't be
shy to answer in the comments section
down below we love to hear what you
think and that's it for 10 Disney
Princesses you never heard of for more
stories like this make sure you watch
this is how Disney Princesses should
have really looked thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]